science and music have been a passion of
mine since i was very young and so they
just came together very naturally
and when i saw an avenue where i could
solidly
take music and science and merge them
together in a super odd way you know it
was hard to resist
[Music]
architect is a performance art group
that specializes in homemade instruments
and we use science to make music
our main crew consists of
three people we just picked up a fourth
person actually that's been going on
more and more shows with us
we made our first musical tesla coils in
2005.
a tesla coil is a high voltage
transformer that takes a voltage and it
converts it to another voltage
and the voltage gets so high that it
creates an artificial lightning bolt
and so the singing tesla coil you hear
it play music but the music is actually
coming from the spark so the lightning
bolt is actually shaking the air and
creating sound pressure waves and we can
change the frequency
of the spark to create different musical
pitches and what we've developed here is
something that is its own unique
instrument
[Music]
the faraday suit is a metal suit you
wear it it's made out of chain mail
which are just chain links that are all
put together they're more conductive
than your body so when you wear the suit
and you get zapped by lightning the suit
protects you from the lightning
we use the suit as a special effect in
our show we use it to play our lightning
guitar it allows us to actually play the
guitar while getting struck by lightning
and people are into that you know
because it looks dangerous and it is
dangerous if you don't have the skills
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we like to go out there and show people
that you can actually have fun with
science right it doesn't have to be just
some super boring thing that you see in
a classroom
when we do our public shows we'll do
some cool science demos we have fun and
we play music you know and then we get
some audience participants to come up
and get zapped by lightning
without the educational aspects what we
do would be incredibly pointless
it gives us a chance to take our
technical skills and put some of that
knowledge out there and actually have
some net benefit to all of it kids are
attracted to things that just can't
easily be explained
and you know let's face it like
electricity is basically magic the
possibilities of what you can do with
electricity are nearly endless
[Music]
you